Після двох років поневірянь у сирійських таборах ці громадянки України нарешті повернулися додому.
У таборах "аль-Хол" і "Родж" утримують десятки тисяч жінок і дітей, які жили на територіях, підконтрольних терористичній організації "Ісламська держава".
За даними правозахисників, там справжня гуманітарна катастрофа: бракує їжі, води і медичної допомоги, діти вмирають від хвороб.
Аміна зі своїми сімома дітьми два роки прожила у такому таборі.
За її словами, там нелюдські умови життя. Відсутність елементарних санітарних умов і ліків не могли не позначитися на здоров'ї дітей.
У соцемережах в коментарях під історіями цих жінок можна прочитати, що вони терористки, загрожують безпеці України,
мають залишатися в Сирії і що самі винні у своїх бідах.
Жінки справді їхали за своїми чоловіками і жили під прапором "Ісламської держави".
Та чи були вони злочинницями? Чи радше заручницями ситуації?
Почесний консул України  в Ербілі Фархад Алі доклав великих зусиль до визвольної операції в Сирії.
Саме він вів переговори з місцевими представниками влади.
На його думку, всі затримані жінки в таборах були причетні до "ІД", оскільки жили на підконтрольних терористам територіях.
Однак якби вони були задіяні у звірствах бойовиків, їх би просто не випустили із Сирії.
Правозахисники і міжнародні організації вважають, що  репатріація - це єдиний правильний вихід для людей, які опинилися в такій ситуації.
Фархад Алі переконаний, що пори минуле жінок залишати громадянок України в таких умовах не можна.
Бабуся Марія, як її називають онуки та невістка, після анексії Криму переїхала з родиною на Вінниччину.
Діти Марії через відсутність роботи шукали заробітку в інших країнах.
Спочатку син забрав всю родину до Туреччини, але потім його плани змінилися.
Попри всі вмовляння, син Марії був непохитним. І жінка з невісткою здалися.
Через два місяці життя в Сирії прийшла звістка, що чоловік загинув.
До кого звернутися у чужому місті, жінки не знали. Самостійно кудись поїхати не наважувалися,
бо постійно чули, що цілі родини підривалися на мінах на виходах з міста.
А тих, кого спіймали при втечі, бойовики "ІД" саджали до в'язниці.
Однак коли почалися бомбові атаки на осередки терористів, українки з дітьми вирушили шукати прихистку в інших селах -
ночували або в покинутих домівках, або просили залишитися у місцевих.
А через місяць настав страшний голод.
Така доля спіткала більшість громадянок України на території Сирії:
поїхали за чоловіками чи синами, сиділи вдома під замком, а коли чоловіків вбили - мусили якось виживати серед бойовиків "Ісламської держави".
Українки добровільно пішли здаватися до таборів, щойно дізналися про їхнє існування.
Після усіх поневірянь Марія досі без сліз не може говорити про день визволення з табору.
Однак тепер жінкам та їхнім дітям треба адаптуватися до нового життя в Україні. У більшості з них немає документів.
Процес поновлення паперів, особливо для дітей, народжених в Сирії, дуже тривалий.
Через це родини не можуть повернутися до нормального життя.
Фатіма Бойко, яка також доклала багато зусиль до повернення жінок, тепер допомагає з адаптацією родин.
Каже, що тяганина з документами дуже ускладнює життя, особливо дітям.
Багато цих жінок родом з Криму. Їхні родичі, які могли б чимось допомогти, тепер живуть на анексованому півострові.
В Україні ці багатодітні жінки, схоже, нікому не потрібні. Вони не мають ані домівок, ані можливості влаштуватися на роботу.
Фатімі вдалося викупити кілька будинків для таких родин на пожертви мусульманської громади. Однак умови в цих будинках спартанські.
Окрім вирішення матеріальних проблем, жінкам і насамперед дітям необхідна психологічна допомога.
Наприклад, у країнах Центральної Азії повернуті із сирійських таборів родини кілька місяців проходять реабілітацію.
В Україні діти навіть ні разу не спілкувалися з психологами.
Деякі діти досі не можуть повірити, що вони вже не в таборі "аль-Хол".
В інших країнах з такими дітьми працюють психологи-теологи.
Щоб заживити всі травми, які вони отримали від тероризму "Ісламської держави", і показати, що є інший іслам.
Тим часом жінки у думках знову і знову переживають жахіття поневірянь у Сирії. Вони мріють про одне.